so I'm Tim maudlin I'm a professor of
philosophy at New York University
[Music]
and you've written a lot or thought a
lot about quantum mechanics and a lot of
people see it as the most accurate is
like giving the most accurate
predictions compared to other scientific
theories at the moment but your latest
what some of your latest work looks at
how quantum theory is actually a
misnomer would you be able to explain
this to us right so there's no doubt and
no one's going to dispute that there's a
mathematical formalism that we know how
to derive predictions from and those
predictions can be accurate to 14
decimal places but what a theory is what
a physical theory is is more than just a
mathematical formalism with some rules
it should specify a physical ontology
which means tell me what exists in the
physical world
are there particles are there fields is
there space-time and tell me about those
things and then specify some laws about
how they behave that tell me how they
behave through time and the problem is
that there is standard quantum what's
taught as quantum theory isn't isn't a
theory in that sense it's just the
formalism and then what people call
interpreting quantum theory which sounds
like a funny thing to do because you'd
say well I have a theory what's an
interpretation what's called
interpreting quantum theory is really
the development of precise physical
theories that make the same predictions
or nearly the same predictions that you
get out of this standard mathematical
recipe and so this to me clears up a
kind of funny question because often
they say Oh a physicist would say well
I've got quantum theory what do I need
an interpretation for what the
philosophers do the interpreting
whatever that is and that's because the
language is misleading them no you don't
have a theory you have a predictive
recipe and what we want as a physicist
what you should want is a theory is
something that makes clear statements
about what the world is
so does that mean that actually quantum
mechanics is a lot stronger in its
predictions than the kind of public
broad audience thinks what does it mean
that they're not there yet and they
still need to work towards having the
stages of the theory well there are
different approaches that people have
been working on this is a very minority
group who work in foundations of physics
so there's a whole approach that goes
back actually to 1925 and Louis
debroglie that's called the pilot wave
theory there's another approach that are
called objective collapse theories and
Roger Penrose is working on those and
some other physicists Giancarlo Girardi
particularly it worked on versions of
objective collapse theories and these
are just different theories and they all
make the same predictions insofar as
they have been tested so far so we can't
go to into a lab and say which of these
approaches is right even though in
principle sometimes these different
approaches make slightly different
predictions you have to think very hard
about how you could actually test them
and what does quantum tell us about
physical reality well that's what's
interesting is that these different
approaches would give you different
answers so if you if I say well I think
it's the pilot wave approach is correct
I'm gonna say well it tells me that the
quantum mechanical wave function is not
a complete physical description and
maybe the world is deterministic and so
on and if I take an objective collapse
theories I'm gonna say that tells me the
world is fundamentally in deterministic
and so there's no single answer to that
the one thing we know for sure is that
there's a kind of nonlocality and this
comes from a theorem of john bell which
doesn't depend on the interpretation
john john bell proved that just certain
results that you get in the lab cannot
be reproduced in a theory that is local
in a certain well-defined sense so there
has to be some non locality
where do you stand amongst these
theories I I mean I have a slight but
this is just my preference my my
aesthetic sense is that the pilot wave
approach seems more natural to me and
the objective collapse approach seems to
me more unnatural but I wouldn't you
know give a lot of attention to my
aesthetic preferences here they're both
very serious they're trying to write the
theory down in completely precise
mathematical terms and everybody should
pay attention to all the going things
that are actually out there that have a
chance of being right what does it mean
that you have like this aesthetic
preference for well in the so in a
collapse theory for example to give you
the reason it's called a collapse theory
is that you have a wave function that
all the theories use and you have
equation Schrodinger's equation which is
a deterministic equation that tells you
how this wave function evolves through
time and in the pilot wave theory that's
the end of it for the wave function
that's all what ever does and in a
collapse theory the wave function
sometimes collapses it does something
very different so for a long time it'll
be doing this and then all of a sudden
it'll do this or do that
and and it'll do that in a completely
random way that the theory will tell you
well there's some chance it'll do this
and some chance it'll do that and in
order to specify that theory you then
need to add some new parameters to tell
me how often this happens at how it
happens and so on so there's more new
data or new constants of nature that go
into specifying that theory whereas in
the pilot wave theory it doesn't have
that and to me that it feels more
natural even Giancarlo Girardi who
developed this objective collapse
theories always said well for him this
was just a kind of stopping point it was
a it was a way toward a deeper theory he
never thought in theory he himself wrote
down felt fundamental to him that he
thought there must be something deeper
beneath it but these are all very
subjective judgments
and I wouldn't put that much weight on
um but to you it is important that
direct impressions inform scientific
theories and for instance you take the
view that time is real and an actual
thing physics any empirical science has
to start from what the philosopher
Wilfred sellers called the manifest
image of the world that is the world as
it presents itself to me when I just
opened my eyes and of course we know
that some of those appearances can be
deceptive or misleading you know the the
or in water looks bent but it really
isn't and so on but you have nowhere
else to begin but with the manifest
image and then you try and produce
theories that would explain it or
account for it and part of the manifest
image of the world is that it's in space
a three-dimensional space and in time
and time goes on and things happen in a
certain sequence and they take different
amounts of time and I can't imagine
really what it would be like to say all
of that is an illusion like the or being
bent in water and there's no reason to
think it is so so especially time
structure we know how to put it into the
fundamental physics and the idea that no
this is all an illusion that derives
from something else I don't even know
how you'd ever get to an idea I mean you
can say oh maybe it's like the matrix
and we're all plugged into a machine by
aliens but there's no way to get to that
right the the hypothesis is built so you
can never test it and so I think there's
been a I think all of the talk about
time being an illusion is just a
misunderstanding of relativity theory
and so on and I diagnosed that in very
specific ways why is it a
misunderstanding of the relativity
theory because relativity doesn't
suggest that all the time is an illusion
it suggests that the temporal structure
of the world isn't what we naively
thought it to be in very specific ways
but that there is time and the time is
directed and
goes from past to future and you can't
go backwards in time all of that is just
the natural way to understand that
there's certainly the way Einstein
understood the theory there's a funny
thing I'll have to mention there was a
note that Einstein wrote a note of
condolence to the family of his friend
Michael besa when he died and this this
note Einstein wrote three months before
he himself died and in it he writes very
poetically about how oh the physicists
now know that time is an illusion and so
on and everybody quotes that as if this
was Einstein's considered scientific
view which it makes no sense whatever
because he never said that in any
scientific paper he never said that in
places where he's expositor the theory
of relativity he was writing a note to
cheer up people who had just lost lost
their son and it was a very kind thing
for him to do but the idea that he had
this view of time that he kept all to
himself until three months before he
died and then and then wrote it down in
a note and and that's how to understand
the theory of relativity that makes no
sense at all but people like it it's
it's the eye if someone says oh time is
an illusion that sounds amazing
you know Wow tell me about that but I
just think there's really nothing to to
it quite honestly is that an issue of
celebrity science in general that we
start mixing up serious work with a
public persona that these scientists
yeah there's that and there's the
temptation quite honestly and it's hard
to resist it certain things are just
sell I mean they're kind of sexy or
they're kind of mind-blowing and there
are some amazing things we've discovered
and I think Belle put his finger on the
fundamental new thing about quantum
mechanics but if someone says oh a cat
can be both alive and dead at the same
time or they're an infinite number of
parallel worlds or something like that
that just sounds like science fiction
and people react in an emotional way to
it and they're attracted to it and so
it's very easy
want to repeat things like that and get
this rise out of the audience you know
you understand that people are tempted
that way but my job is to try and say
look let's slow down here they're very
interesting results but let's not mix
them up with pure speculation or you
know things that just sound so any of
you then Schrodinger's cat is just a
sexy kind of what the Schrodinger cat
thought experiment when Schrodinger
wrote it down had a very serious point
and his point was that the understanding
of quantum mechanics that Bohr and
Heisenberg had produced which goes by
the name of the Copenhagen
interpretation was completely
unacceptable because it had this
consequence that a cat could end up
neither alive or dead and Schrodinger
said that's ridiculous right that tells
you you've made a mistake Bohr right
that tells you you've made a mistake
Heisenberg go back and think again and
so the example had a very serious
purpose the purpose wasn't to convince
you that there are cats that are neither
dead or alive that was supposed to be
the absurd consequence of a bad
interpretation that tells you don't
think that way we needed you know we
need to understand this theory but now
we've we have this theory presented as
reflecting in quantum mechanics in
physics textbooks yep how did we get
here it's a we got here because the
there were really two phases to this I
think one was early on Niels Bohr who
had some kind of amazing magnetic
personality that I don't understand but
you just see his effect on people he
loved these kind of weird Gnostic hard
to understand pronouncements and and he
thought the key to quantum mechanics was
that you couldn't understand it in
normal ways of thought and we sort of
reached the limit of our intuitive
understanding of the world and he pushed
that very hard and said a lot of very
obscure and inscrutable things and and
very strongly enforced that other people
say this
and people like Einstein just never put
up with it I mean that's why Einstein
hey you know really did not like war and
the Copenhagen and he was always
fighting against it because it didn't
make any sense and it was obscure and so
this the few people who were fighting
against it really got sidelined very
politically and then when it came to the
United States all of this Borean kind of
hard to understand semi mystical
philosophy got kind of thrown away and
then it became shut up and calculate so
they said we'll just don't ask us
questions like what's really going on
just we have a thing that you can use to
make good predictions just use it to
make the predictions and don't ask these
and that when I studied physics as an
undergraduate that happened to me in my
first quantum mechanics course I put up
my hand and asked the physics professor
well is it like this and he and his
answer was no you can't think of it that
way but then he didn't go on to say
here's how you think of it it's like
don't think of it right you know I just
calculate the numbers and so this shut
up and you know this was has become
known it's not quite clear who started
this is shut up and calculate and that's
a practical point of view if all you
care about is making predictions but if
you care about what the world really is
not about building bridges or making
microchips but if you're just curious
what's really going on shut up and
calculate doesn't get you anywhere and
so the physics textbooks are all written
by people who never studied these
questions because they were told not to
ask them and not to think about them
they were very exquisitely told do not
think about these questions but if a
theory helps you make predictions and
shouldn't get also that doesn't it take
what the world really is or what reality
really is into account let me give you a
very simple example people knew for
thousands and thousands of years ago
that aspirin will actually have medical
uses it'll make your headaches go away
they knew that empirically they didn't
have a clue even long into the 20th
century how it works
they knew you took the bark of a certain
tree and you chewed it or whatever and
your headache went
now if all you care about is getting rid
of your headache you're happy you don't
care how it works so you can have
something that tells you very
effectively practically what to do and
not have a clue why it works you may
know that it works but not it but not
have a clue how it works yes it is
exactly what's happened in quantum
theory we have a very effective
mathematical recipe for grinding out
predictions and those predictions are
really accurate so there's something in
that recipe that reflects the real world
but exactly what reflects the real world
and how you can stare at that
mathematics from morning till night and
the mathematics won't tell you you'll
need a physical theory um so the way you
present the kind of fight for truth in
quantum physics sounds like a bit of a
power struggle what's the role of power
in science
well powers there are some people who
literally are good at wielding
institutional power and in academia you
know you have to get a position you have
to get tenure if you're a physicist and
you are interested in these foundational
questions it will kill your career or it
used to now it's a bit better but there
was certainly a time where literally you
could not get a job if you said I'm
interested in the foundations of quantum
mechanics not in a physics department
you could get one in a philosophy
department and maybe you could get one
in a math department as a mathematical
physicist and the hardest place was in a
physics department there are some people
who you know really and Bohr early on
knew how to use institutional power but
that's not usually what happens more
it's just you do what your professors do
you know you're you're brought up in a
certain culture and if then the culture
is don't ask these questions you just
don't ask them and if you then go on to
teach you tell your students don't ask
them so it's not so much the imposition
of power in a hard way it's just the
kind of influence that
the general zeitgeist around you hands
what would you like to happen in the
academic environment in particularly in
what physicists are doing about quantum
now uh what I really want to happen what
I'm working hard right now in a
practical way to happen is simply to
have foundations of physics recognized
institutionally as a legitimate
enterprise that it's it's something that
some people can devote their lives to
and if you're a physicist who doesn't
care about it and you just want to make
the predictions or you just want to run
the experiment fine but you say there
are these people who are interested in
this question and they're doing also a
serious kind of work and to have it have
it recognized institutionally it would
be nice if every student who learned
quantum mechanics at least got a 3-page
accurate description of the situation
right if you really want to understand
the foundations and you have to have
classes and foundations sometimes I mean
I physicists have this idea because they
have a physics PhD they must they must
know all these answers and if you then
but then you have to ask well where did
you learn it it wasn't in your textbooks
you never learn foundations you never
took a course in it you never read a
chapter about it you never read a book
about it why do you think you know about
it all I really want people to do is to
recognize that this is a serious work
and they're serious people some people
in physics departments on people in math
departments some people in philosophy
departments working on a common project
and it's a legitimate project thank you
so much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you